hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP Kadeem man
preach now on the other side of this
door is no no no no no no I'm sorry sir
somewhere else because I'm not needed
over here so I'm not i god damn it does
that again oh good lordy ha ha ha
god damn it shut up no no no no no no no
no no Kylie as loud as ball now anyway
there's been a few bugs with the version
1.0 release but i'm very close to
getting to that new area I got the key
right now and I got the door right back
there I'm hoping if I go far enough away
and then I come back they're gonna be
gone and then I'm going to be able to
get into there I may have needed to open
the door but god damn oh well I have no
choice now I got to go back but god damn
god you douches you sounds so serious
right here we go he's gonna run away
anybody there any nine-tailed Fox's no
I'm not a bastard my name is markiplier
I'm a highly trained doctor specializing
in butt surgery
hello no no no no no no no no I need to
get through there okay no no where am i
SCP ma RK i ple IR power do you dude ah
Billy bill I'm right here
Oh Polly hurts okay now is not
beneficial to my survival I have a trick
that I very rarely use but just
restorations just like this and they
required I'm an SCP now again SCP ma RK
I feel I are flying through space well
you can see already through well you can
go now
why are you through the wall that is
very weird
are you also se Peas are you scary
monsters I let him down this you're not
gonna show me are you God Oh
wait you're not moving um such dick bags
goddamnit will they get me from over
here where Oh God
yeah but ah you're such an ass
so the sound of my blood leaking out of
my body
why oh I'm still alive oh that ain't
good
well not I'll take the back left okay
okay it looks like they have vacated the
air the area huh therefore I should be
able to not noclip anymore and use this
key on that door in there that is the
theory anyway
so let's see if they're still there oh
well they open the other door for me but
that's the door that I'm very much
interested in no kidding
sorry okay
I'll just go to the door now cuz I don't
know when I'm gonna be able to go in
again
oh I don't have many frames excuse me
for oh hi okay that was weird
okay I do now oh that's me oh that's me
walking around oh my god I can't believe
I'm here I'd seen clues and stuff about
this for a long time and I read up on
the story I didn't think I'd actually be
here this is weird cuz there's been the
I of the drawing of the keyhole looking
through to the forest this is where the
Slenderman lives
it's a Slenderman SCP can the Slenderman
be contained within this facility
II wear this all looks all lovely
electic get to the ball hello mrs. Chloe
eyes over there should I look at you
you're very pretty
so hello you're a thing your I see a
thing
can i well know away some don't feel
right here I don't know if it's the
dialogues what hi okay bye
you want to come out and play friend you
want to you want to be my friend I don't
have any friends here and the ones I do
are counted douches Billy's an a-hole oh
good I get a choice well I'm gonna die
I'm sorry
Oh what I do with you oh you're so
pretty I'm so pretty oh this is nugget
alright I can't run I'm dead what's up
god oh
Oh as a bad idea go to there is it right
behind me if I turn around am I gonna
see a very disturbing creature epic
proportions
kiya fraid to same time I really wanna
hey where am I going
what am I do was that okay Oh run Oh
can't run no running I'm dead I'm
already dead can I go up in the woods
oh it's ripe I'm here then bye
alright back in I'm sorry about the low
framerate in here there's a bug that was
written in the chains log for version
1.0 3 where they fix it but
unfortunately couldn't load up my same
so I'm stuck here I'm gonna give this
one more try legitimately and then I'm
gonna use my SCP powers to find the end
of this cuz I know you guys want to find
it Barbara
Oh dead end that's good I like that
house very girls I can't wait oh I'm
dead
oh okay that's good do that's good I
like that that's good that's good Donna
thank you God those this one NCP that I
just read on the wiki I I don't even
remember what name it was or what number
but basically it would go to a house
where someone lived alone and its
containment was that it just had someone
else living next to it and then it would
go out every once in a while hunting for
a new person to keep company and he'd
absorb them into their chest and call
them family rip out their eyes and make
them forget who they were or make them
fall in love or I don't know but it's
really messed up if anyone knows what
I'm talking about please write it down
in the description below okay did I find
thee can I find the end this is where I
needed to be I don't know oh god oh god
no oh I collapsed of a heart attack
three three active instances of scp-498
unalloyed CP what huh okay let's try
this again
okay got it oh wait what oh I just
popped out on the other side that was so
useless cuz the door was already open
over there but okay I'm gonna be happy
I'm gonna say because holy hell this is
lagging my computer like a son of a
I don't let this to crash I've
come so far okay so hooray I made it to
the other side of the room that's good I
guess so that means that I can continue
through the game
I guess what is this ain't be it be OS
right yeah JB I can't open JP because
the computer guys keeping gabe being
nice and locked tight
good for him i'm gonna try to explore
some more maybe else what is that okay i
got it man maintain operations whatever
blah blah blah
Godwine my framerate so yes look I
haven't seen one of you in a while
come on Tesla game whoa that's new whoa
whoa no get someone's been beefed up
quite a bit
I do appreciate a good decent dinner
well what was even the point of that I
gotta go back oh oh it's so potent and
powerful mmm makes one flatly erogenous
ah crap Gate a damn you computer on I
need to get out of here oh I gotta go
back uh stupidity well apparently the
only way to get to gates a and B is to
go through the door anyway but I did
that and so now all I have to do is just
go around and I have to suffer through
this low framerate right here so sorry
about that no Billy no Billy Billy Billy
where are you Billy Billy Billy
hi you can't give me from all the way
across there right yeah that's right
hello hi my name is more Gloria oh hey
yo cause wait a minute what this is not
where I was different place yeah yeah
yeah you can't do nothing you can't do
none to me okay so basically the frame
rate was getting so bad that I just
decided to get to the new version and
what I'm gonna do is I'm literally gonna
play through and try to get back to
exactly where I was before but this is
gonna take a while so just sit back and
relax and enjoy the montage of scares
well I sounds pretty excessively bad
that sounds much worse than I remembered
when I first started playing oh come on
I can't go through there seriously Billy
I don't like you I don't wanna be
friends you're the worst dad way oh okay
hi and
Thanks radical Larry it's just what I
wanted okay okay good finally get here
is where I wanted to be the only way to
get a higher little key card Oh a memory
access violation good momentary reprieve
from the torment at hand
oh yeah this time no day no next snap no
no no Billy no no no Billy no no don't
kill me no no no no no no no no where'd
you oh hey he's your friend hey can I
get that gam card thank you out of here
out of here out of here close it close
it go in it good you just have a yard
I can't possibly under lots of makeup
screw are you it is Marta Barry you
can't see me I'm invisible to you and
you were doing but why oh god what are
you wearing
oh no I don't know what are you are you
Sabrina are you Sally sue Sally
Struthers Struthers a Sabrina which one
are you identify yourself I'm going I'm
Audi yeah yeah oh yeah battery smoking
hot boy oh god what okay that was good
oh now it opens
perfect timing elevator buddy why do I
keep going back now why do I keep doing
this to myself why No thank you I'm
sneaky stuff darling no no for some
reason you were able to get me before
but not this time this time this time
not now not ever
not ever alright so I'm done for this
episode but don't worry in the next
episode when I try to get to the newer
not new but updated endings I'm gonna
scoot ahead into the future so that I'm
already to the point where I could be
almost there already so thanks again
everybody for watching hope you enjoyed
my daughter and check out the other
scary games in the annotation and
description below thanks again and as
always I will see you in next video bye
bye
the war and everyone died
kill these doors